josée legault paul journet michel surgit
bonsoir mon petit tour de table sur la
coved
parce que bon on a dépassé le cap des
6000 décès faut quand même le souligner
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont morts
pour le rappeler
je vous montre une courbe oui ça s'est
stabilisé au cours des derniers jours
neuf cent soixante neuf nouveaux cas
aujourd'hui où le voyez sur lacombe il
ya clairement de stabilisation par
rapport à il ya deux semaines mais comme
a dit le ministre josé c'est là qu'on
voit quand même aujourd'hui en nombre de
décès ce qu'on a connu il ya quelques
semaines
oui c'est c'est quand même grave c'est
que le québec est passé le cap des 6000
membres et que les personnes qui en sont
mortes des hommes les femmes du québec
ça continue à s'accumuler et ça c'est un
peu le sait un peu les canaris dans la
mineure parce que bon ça va avec le
nombre de cos avoir été longue de
spécialisation etc et aujourd'hui on a
eu aussi une autre on a appris aussi que
près de 14000 travailleurs la santé
travailleurs travailleuses avaient été
infectés de l'aco vides certains en sont
morts
écoutez ça va ça va pas ça va pas
nécessairement très très bien monsieur
legault aujourd'hui comparé le nombre de
nouveaux candidats mais quand on se
compare on se console
il ya en france par exemple c'est plus
trente mille cas aujourd'hui quotidien
mais quand on regarde le nombre de décès
depuis le début par million d'habitants
on est obligé de dire très clairement
que le québec est parmi les pires et la
belgique l'espagne québec arrive en 3ème
états unis en dessous nous royaume uni
en dessous l'union suède et france donc
ça c'est aussi une réalité
incontournable quand un russe consoler
on choisit avec qui on se compare mais
si on se compare avec la moyenne des
pays de l'osce et des appuis avec les
autres provinces canadiennes
on sait au québec qui ça va mal on est
en queue de peloton et en plus des
chiffres sur les mares où on attend
le chiffre cumulatif des morts et le
chiffre de nombre de cas où on atteint
des niveaux très inquiétants
puis on revient à la situation qui
prévalait le printemps dernier
il ya des effets cumulatifs c'est à dire
que même si on atteint le même nombre de
points que le printemps dernier et des
effets cumulatifs par rapport à la
fatigue du personnel soignant
ils sont encore plus fatigué en ce
moment et plus épuisés qu'ils ne
l'étaient le printemps dernier et il ya
aussi les effets cumulatifs du report
d'autres actes médicaux par exemple est
ce c'est peut-être la face cachée des
les bilans de chez nous même si monsieur
legault avait raison que en se comparant
on n'est pas si pire ne faut pas oublier
que lire certains dégâts qu'on ne va
pouvoir constater que dans les prochains
mois est ce à dire tous les gens malades
dont deux pauvres gamins réussi à
prendre soin comme on le réduit où et
puis on les cas se multiplient la tue
les gens qui nous dit j'avais une
opération urgente elle été annulée
c'était michel sauget michel le bot
choisit toujours sont comparables selon
situation afin à chaque journée donc un
moment donné on peut pas nécessairement
savoir ce que ce qui est ce qui est la
vraie situation du québec sur lémance
c'est très grave si on se compare à la
france soit un nombre de codes celle des
moins aujourd'hui c'est quand même pas
extraordinaires comme comme situation
et est ce qu'on sait aussi c'est que
d'un système hospitalier est vraiment
l'association du célèbre qu'est ce que
je peux à lui bien sûr ses chances oui
dans tout ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
on a vu que aussi des nouvelles
nominations
quand même ils s'inquiètent même si bon
évidemment le message est différent
bon il ya un nouveau sous-ministre qui a
été nommé à l'éducation
on a posé la question ce que ça veut
dire que jean françois roberge le
ministre a besoin d aide
on a répondu non mais de toute évidence
à chaud son chagrin
l'ancien chef jacques cartier par dont
l'ancien chef de cabinet de mario dumont
je crois qu'il a été nommé voilà est
aussi au menu de rater un oui au nouveau
sous-ministre adjoint à la santé qui va
travailler avec horacio arruda
et c'est jérôme gagnon et monsieur me
suivait l'a décrit comme celui qui
allait s'occuper de
l'opérationnalisation sur le terrain
donc celui qui va s'occuper un peu plus
du dépistage du traçage et c est ça
aussi ça nous dit qu'à la santé publique
nationale du côté de monsieur à khudobin
il ya des gars des manquements hockey
liberté je le disais c'est un sujet
important puis on a soufflé trois fois
qu'on voulait faire il ya eu ce calvaire
si d'ottawa qui nous a remis ça c'est
isabelle h et dans chez vous paul qui a
parlé de soi ce matin c'est vraiment des
camps et keita ou mais on suspend des
enseignants parce que les plaintes de
d'étudiants parce que l
dans le cas d'une explication la
n'insultait pas des étudiants à utiliser
le mot commence par n
dans un autre cas l'avait cité livre de
pierre vallières [ __ ] blancs
d'amérique dans un autre bon bref tous
les nobles là-dessus êtes vous inquiet
de voir ces cas se multiplier et surtout
pas tellement que des étudiants se
plaignent mais je pense ça peut être
tout à fait normal mais que les
autorités des universités mettre de côté
ses enseignants un poste qu'on savait
croix rouge oui je suis inquiet et je ne
suis pas le seul faut rappeler qu'il ya
un groupe de travail qui a remis son
rapport il ya quelques semaines sur
l'avenir des universités y avait
plusieurs sujets l'un d'eux s'était la
hausse de la censure sur les campus
donc ça se passe au québec même si on
observe davantage dans le canada anglais
et vous savez patrice g c'est sur ce
genre de questions identitaires d'avoir
un point de vue nuancé mais des fois il
n'y a pas de place pour la nuance il ya
des choses qui doivent être dénoncés et
j'ai une seule façon de qualifier
l'attitude de l'université d'ottawa
celle htc de la totale l'a achetée par
rapport à l'enseignante et il ya un
élément d'explication additionnel qu'il
faut apporter ce que l'enseignante
voulait faire l'exemple qu'elle
utilisait elle parlait d'art
si sts qui s'approprie une expression
qui était a priori insultante et qui
l'utilisent de façon dont pour pour
réaffirmer leur identité d'une façon
positive du renversement et la
professeure ne voulait expliquer ça et
il ya des gens qui lorsqu'on veut
transmettre du savoir se braque et
préfère l'ignorance et la censure sans
procès c'est quelque chose
d'inacceptable dont inchangés mais je
suis tout à fait d'accord
reste que pour bien dire et patrice
avait posé la bonne question le lévy le
vrai problème ici c'est la direction de
l'université d'ottawa qui ont qui au
lieu de défendre son enseignante a
nourri cette espèce d'atmosphère
d'inquisition lorsqu'elle a fait
absolument rien de mal
le mot qui commence par la lettre n le
pot utilisé pour insulter des personnes
noires dans sa classe mais dans un
contexte pédagogique très très très
spécifique est tout à leur joie par des
fabris ville de parler de dialogue des
charges
sauf tout le respect qu'on lui doit dans
des situations comme ça il n'y a pas de
dialogue de possibles alors lorsque
l'enseignante s'est fait dire par une
étudiante sur mollo ne devrait jamais
sortir de la bouche d'une blanche
quel que soit le contexte de j'ajoute
c'est quand même incroyable qu'une
université baptisée ça c'est sûr que
défendre son assaillant parce qu'encore
une fois que des étudiants qui sont à
sur bella dans cette mouvance l'actuel
maps on peut comprendre réagissent comme
ça premier degré ok très bien mais qu'il
y ait pas d autorité universitaire vous
êtes dans une salle de classe
on est dans le lieu de savoir de liberté
michel c'est angers et je vois utiliser
l'expression qui est devenu célèbre dans
une campagne électorale mme audi alteram
partem ya des préceptes de justice
naturelle aussi et de ses principes de
justice naturelle là il ya le fait qu'on
doit écouter toutes les parties
la professeure avons été écoutés été
suspendu environ cinq ans de plus mais
lui demander son avis ou de ses
explications
ça ça n'a pas de sens et ça n'a pas de
sens
sur comme l'univers strict qui a une
faculté de droit c'est-à-dire connu
d'ailleurs et qui ne peut pas demander à
ses enseignants de travailler dans des
circonstances pareilles ça n'a pas de
sens
quant au canton mot lui-même bas il
faudra l'envi de la couverture d'un des
livres de dany laferrière sont pas de la
pub non on avait un extra de données
laferrière tout à l'heure très justement
dans l'âme on la laissera pas gêné non
la lettre lui dit vous avez le droit et
ce qu'ils utilisent à mauvais escient ce
qu'ils veulent l'insulté avec ce mot là
bas ils vont à payer le prix de toute
façon psy malien qui en paient le prix
mais ce we alesi part je vous écouterai
deux autres commentaires rapides c'est
des étudiants en art depuis quand les
étudiants en art sont à ce point fragile
et conservateur est aussi faut se
rappeler qui est à la tête de
l'université d'ottawa
jacques frémont qui était avant à la
tête de la commission des droits de la
personne spécialiste en liberté
fondamentale en tout cas c'est silence
radio parce qu'on a tout essayé pour
avoir des recteurs des vice-recteurs
appelez ça comme vous voulez la
direction quelconque de quelconques
universités on a ratissé très large les
gens ne veulent pas beaucoup parlé de
choses qui est aussi inquiétant quand
même mais espérons patrice qui sont
peut-être occupé à rédiger leurs excuses
à l'enseignante
peut-être parce que le lancer
ça donne quelque chose ou coureurs
prirent des choses comme ça parce que là
on joue inverti madame et messieurs
pendant deux minutes on va reparler de
raciste systémique alors vous pouvez
commencer à écrire vos courriels mais
c'est parce que fannie lafontaine avant
4 qui a été mandatée pour examiner le
travail des policiers vous avez les
autochtones dit on a là on va on va
prendre un petit extrait de ce qu'elle
me dire quelques minutes on n'a pas elle
me disait que pour elle je dis oui mais
ce qu'on peut sans reconnaître avancer
les choses a dit peut-être mais cette
début quand même
selon elle il faut reconnaître que dans
certains systèmes policiers mes chances
et augé ya ce que l appel du raciste
systémique
je note que les gens qui ont passé du
temps à examiner la situation des
relations entre les
autochtone et les policy ces dernières
années au québec on touche qu conclu à
la même chose
il semble qu'on puisse pas dire le move
à ce que le premier ministre veut pas
qu'on dise ça me fait penser quand on
avait demandé des députés conservateurs
dans le temps des manoeuvres
constitutionnel des années 90 là essayez
donc de dire par société distincte à
brac les gens attendaient un député que
je pense que c'est jean pierre blackburn
qui avait 10 parfait on peut pas plus un
show on dirait que c'est un minou puis
c'est surtout mais à la fin on a
exactement la même barre par madame la
fontaine qui est un juriste reconnu qui
est quelqu'un de très sérieux on a le
même constat que celui du juge vient à
un moment donné quelque part il y a un
problème
appelons ça comme on voudra mais de
consulter une nation systémique et il va
falloir qu'on vient de faire six minutes
en disant qu'on peut pas on peut pas
éliminer des mots il les faire
disparaître de notre vision parce qu'on
les aime pas paul bayle le rapport la
commission vin vient parler de
discrimination systémique non pas de
racisme systémique mais c'est parce que
c'était dans le libellé de son mandat
cela dit je trouve que de se demander
c'est du racisme systémique ou non à la
limite d'un débat qui devient un écran
parce que tout le monde va y aller avec
sa propre opinion puis on ne parle pas
de ce qui est important c'est à dire des
manifestations de racisme systémique et
c'est ça qui est documentée dans le
rapport et dont vous faut rappeler quand
même le madame la fontaine y deux phases
à son enquête
on n'est qu'à la phase ii il y avait un
petit plus que 60 cas je pense dont
environ le tiers impliqué des policiers
des policiers allochtone le deux tiers
des policiers autochtones mais on voit
que des rapports très très complexe où
ça va au delà des la théorie des pommes
pourries des des gestes individuelles
isolées passagers vraiment des pratiques
culturelles enracinée dans les
institutions et c'est de ces pratiques
là qu'il faut parler au lieu de se
demander si oui ou non c'est du racisme
et miquelon le rapport il ya en france
plus de 260 pages le donc ça va au delà
d'un seul terme
oui bien sûr bien sûr j'ai oui on parle
vraiment
de racisme discrimination utiliser
l'euro que vous voulez le kiki qui s'est
installée de manière systémique non pas
systématique mais système et on a vu on
a eu la nouvelle encore une fois il ya
un autre homme nati mattel qui est
décédé à l'hôpital de chicoutimi qui
s'était plaît aussi d'avoir été victime
de remarques racistes ce sont des
allégations là on n'a pas de preuves
vidéo comme le cas de joe hisaishi
s'il vous plaît aussi qu'un problème
sérieux moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est que
avec le débat sur l'expression racisme
systémique
on est en train de polariser on est en
train de polariser l'association à la
femme dans la société québécoise là
entre les ceux qui pensent qu'il y en
ait officieux qui pensent qu'un apport
et les pouvoirs politiques le font mais
pendant ce temps là en effet que se
passe-t-il sur le terrain et ça c'est
attendons les recommandations donc de ce
comité il y en a plusieurs mais dans ce
que s'il y en a un à québec envers merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir parlé de
tout ça c'est des sujets portés
aujourd'hui mais vous avez vous toujours
mais aujourd'hui particulièrement merci
a bientot au revoir au revoir merci